miller hélène ce qui reste très offensif
dans le ton qui dénonce des crimes de
guerre de la part des russes ses troupes
russes pour une sortie de crise
diplomatique néanmoins bruno daroux il
faut une solution personnes
n'apparaissent comme vaincus est ce
envisageable à ce stade franchement non
c'est compliqué parce qu'en fait on
vient de le voir le président zelensky
reste extrêmement combatif non seulement
la sur le moment présent il dénonce
effectivement les bombardements russes
parlant de de crimes de guerre de crimes
contre l'humanité donc ça veut dire
qu'ils pensent et déjà à la suite 1 et
d'ailleurs il dit non seulement va tenir
bon mais nous allons gagner et nous
allons gagner et la paix reviendra et
nous allons reconstruire il vient
d'annoncer qu'il ya quatre fonds pour la
reconstruction du pays qui ont déjà été
monté en quelque sorte pour après la
guerre donc en fait il est dans une
position pas du tout deux de quelqu'un
qui dit bon faisons faisons du mieux
qu'on peut on va essayer de résister
mais dire non non on va continuer à se
battre et on va et on va l'emporter donc
un discours extrêmement combatif donc
effectivement on attend le troisième
round de pourparlers entre les russes et
les positions sont carrément aux
antipodes en fait ils vont peut-être
progressé sur voilà le davantage de
couloirs humanitaires ce genre de choses
mais évidemment entre les deux bandes de
vladimir poutine qui demande quasiment
la lafa pas quasiment qui demande la
reddition de l'armée ukrainienne le
changement de régime et les demandes de
devenir zelensky qui demandent à la
russie d'arrêter son agression qui
suggère que donc elle devra répondre de
ses actes devant une justice
internationale évidemment les positions
sont complètement complètement
incompatible non par ailleurs il a
annoncé donc les russes s'apprêtait à
bombarder la ville stratégique du port
d'odessa quelle est l'importance de
cette ville pour les russes alors il en
a parlé effectivement le président dans
son intervention il a dit selon lui
d'ailleurs que des missiles et des
lance-roquettes en tout cas ont commencé
à être tirés sur au dessin qui est donc
effectivement voilà
la troisième ville du pays donc c'est
effectivement très important c'est un
port sur la mer noire donc ça contrôler
le maire nord parce que tout ce que les
russes ont fait pour le moment en
partant de l'est le sud la crimée ils
ont complètement gagné le contrôle de la
petite mer d'azov que vous voyez là et
là évidemment s'ils prennent au dessin
c'est a deux avantages d'ailleurs ce
sera peut-être pris aussi par là par la
mer parce que il ya beaucoup de navires
us qui sont stationnés l'avantagé que
c'est un contrôle de toute cette côte
mais côté mer noire cette fois ci avec
des tas de conséquences économiques
notamment d' pour l'ukraine et les
expériences geste voilà et deuxième
objectif c'est de pousser de pousser ce
continuum territoriales jusqu'à la
frontière avec la moldavie qui se trouve
là qu'est ce qui est à l' on ne voit pas
sur cette carte mais il ya cette région
autoproclamée pro-russe de la
transnistrie donc en fait ce serait une
véritable continuité territoriale que
organiserait la russie merci beaucoup